bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you I may be your host
you're watching the Deen show and I have
the author of how do they miss dr. Hakim
quick and Valentine's Day is right
around the corner and after this show
you'll never look at Valentine's Day
again the same we got some facts not
fiction for you to give you the origins
of Valentine's and then let you at the
end decide is this something I should be
celebrating that I should bring and
incorporate into my life and what my
children and my family we're gonna let
you be the judge after this exciting
show about Valentine's Day here on the
deans show don't go nowhere
welcome back to the Dean show and in the
Deano studio dr. Abdullah Hakim quick
Salam alaikum alaikum Salaam Allah
please be with you how are you I'm doing
laughs I'm very excited you know what
this is what we call the destiny of the
Creator that happens in earth because
let me tell you what was going on in my
mind you know I was thinking like a hum
did Allah word got out that you're
coming into town at the DePaul
University you're giving a lecture and
but I'm traveling on the weekend but
your lectures on the weekend I'm like
you know what and and the the the
brothers uh from Al Maghrib I used to
know the the former Emir there so nobody
reached out to me usually we used to
collaborate and anybody will come out
you know and we'll get him on the show
so it just I was like you know what I
was a little sad I said man you know
he's gonna be busy and I'm gonna be
traveling but then I get the call
Youssef ISA gives me a call the the
brother who's the attorney who
approached you and he said I'm here with
double sheikh abdul-hakeem quick I said
the Dean shall tell him we is is he
available let's do the show because
we've worked together before you know
and then we get on the phone
Allah made it happen and we're here
again I'm did Allah I'm doing amazing so
that was very interesting so let me as I
open the show we talk we're talking
about now this holiday that's coming up
Valentine's Day mmm
and you know this is something that you
know is is dominant now and in the
culture you know and so we want to
educate the people somewhat of the roots
to talk about the roots where this is
coming from and at the end you know let
the people make a sound decision you
know is this something really that I
want to teach my children this is
something that I want to propagate my
family and a lot of Muslims in holidays
you know Valentine's hits the women
start in some of the schools I don't you
notices they started to wear the pink he
jobs
the boys were in a pink shirt
you know it's all innocent but at the
end you know faatima gets pregnant or
John you know has a baby out of wedlock
and then what it's not so innocent
anymore so let's talk about Valentine's
nation bismillah ar-rahman ar-rahim will
be in a stay in Rabat it is important
for us when we look at the issue of
holiday myths that we look at the whole
picture and from the beginning of time
people worshiped the Creator in
different ways the Quran tells us in the
chapter of the be certain now well Akkad
bath Navi coonley or mutton rasuluh
enabled ilaha watched any bethought and
verily we have sent to every nation a
messenger that they worship Allah and
stay away from false gods so amongst the
people there were those who believed in
one God but there were also people who
base their religion on natural things so
they based their religions on the
movement of the Sun the stars at the
heavenly bodies also on the natural
seasons so whether it's summer season
fall winter spring also on reproduction
so the the mysteries of sexual activity
and reproduction within nature so these
nature groups spread throughout the
world and they came in contact with the
teachings of Jesus easily Salam when
some of his followers ended up in Greece
and in Rome and we know that these
followers to a great extent were
influenced by Paul who had accepted his
teachings but then started to change the
message somewhat sort of opening up the
doors for other types of beliefs now
what comes out of this is that the
Romans reacted against the believers in
one God and they began to torture them
so you'd see that not only the
gladiators and the Colosseum's
but also Christians were being tortured
thrown to the Lions and the hyenas and
the dogs and so somewhere along the line
somebody said or did the old saying if
you can't beat them join them
and so an amalgamation between the
nature-based religions and the belief
and one God came about so that what
existed was a new religion a new form of
spirituality and and that combined the
basis of it was that these these three
elements the movement of the seasons the
heavenly bodies and sexuality and so the
the cults began to influence and so we
are going into February now and coming
out of January coming out of the new
years and that was a big confusion for a
lot of Muslims because December 25th was
not actually the birthday of Christ he
wasn't born on December no I mean most
theologians will agree he was born in
the warm weather yeah even in the
Christian belief the the shepherds were
had their flocks outside they were
paying their taxes and the taxes were
paid with ripened fruits and these only
come about in the warm seasons though
the Islamic concept has Mary Mary and
may Allah be pleased with her being told
by the angel shake the date palm tree
and the ripe dates will come down that
happens in the in the warm season now
you you are I when I introduce the show
I mean when I introduce you before you
you came out I said you're a historian
is that you study this in depth right I
have a PhD a masters and a PhD from the
University of Toronto and also it was my
it's my passion to study history and to
look at the roots of words and what
influences us in the world today so when
you look at the season now people are
talking about the birth of Christ but
actually the ceremony that is going on
is the Bacchanalia of the Greeks and the
Saturnalia of the Romans and this was a
drunken orgy and so many different
strange things are happening and this is
the reason why people get confused in
the Christmas season because it's
supposed to be the birthday of Christ
but there is more alcohol being drunk
more people being raped more deaths on
the highway than any other time of the
year so that's where you get those
clashes between the two now going into
Jan you
the solar calendar tells us that
actually the new year is not January and
people say well how can you say this but
let's count in Latin September is septum
that's 7 October like an octagon 8 sides
that's the eighth month of the year
November is 9 and December is the 10th
month of the year not the 12th month the
other solar year that's clear in the
Latin the 11th month was January and the
12th month is February so the beginning
of the year for the people who followed
the seasons wasn't much ok so January
was based on Janice who is the two-faced
God he's got one face of spirituality
and another face of materialism and
that's the hypocritical nature of the
New Year's celebration it's supposed to
be a spiritual event but actually again
people are drinking alcohol and being
involved in a lot of riotous occasions
so so this is the confusion now going
into February into February now there
was a there was a celebration done by
the Romans called the Lupercalia and the
Lupercalia was based upon their gods of
pan and Juno and they also February is
actually named after one of their gods
as well and so this is a time where
you're coming out of the winter and
you're going toward the spring season
and so they used to have large
gatherings of young people and they
would take the name of women put them in
a large container and the men would
choose them and literally have a sexual
relationship so it was based upon this
you know Cupid concept the Greek word is
eros this is modern Dame Valentine's
yeah so I want to tell you where it
worth comes in though yeah
the Greek word is eros erotica okay so
erotica is is basically sexuality and so
that that was the main issue on this
occasion and this is where you get
Cupid's from in hots and things like
that because this is actually
the ceremony of you know open sexuality
what happened was they combined this
with an individual named Valentine who
in the Roman times and in the third
century of the Roman era he was
protecting young people the Romans said
no marriage because we want men to fight
strong and in battle so we're not gonna
let you get married Valentine you know a
religious priest he disagreed with this
they put him in jail he went against the
state eventually they executed him and
on the day of his execution he wrote a
letter to two of the young people
getting married and he said from your
Valentine's so that's where Valentine
he's st. Valentine's so so so they took
the concept of the open sexuality put
the name of a Christian priest on it so
it seems like a holy day but actually
it's the open sexuality of the
Lupercalia and that is the dangerous
thing for Muslims and people of
conscience to get involved in this
because what happens is pornography
erotica this overcomes everything else
so it seems like it's innocent it's like
they say a wolf in sheep's clothing it
seems like it's innocent because
Valentine was protecting young people
but the reality is it is an occasion
where more people commit fornication and
adultery where rape happens unwanted
pregnancy it is actually a dangerous
time we're gonna take a break shape
we're gonna continue on here with the
Valentine's holiday that is right around
the corner and we want you to be
educated so we got an educated historian
here
to kind of give you the roots of it and
we're gonna be asking some more
questions here on the details so don't
go nowhere do you think these things are
gonna bring you happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction
it's going to end up causing you if it
hasn't already a lot of pain you're
happy what we are offering in Islam what
we have found in Islam for ourselves is
a means by which our hearts are in peace
they're at rest they're not discontent
we are pleased with what we have
back here on the Dean show with dr.
sheikh abdul-hakeem quick we're talking
about Valentimes right around the corner
tell us now okay
so is there anything more to the route
here started off with something of
promiscuity so erotic you know it's not
about getting together in marriage the
way the crater wants this is just you
know just just hookup you know freestyle
whatever goes so they take this this
christian man his name is Valentine put
his name on top of it and call it
Valentine's right so he is an innocent
person he is a religious person who's
protecting young people
yeah and wanting them to get married
according to the rules of the church
yeah but but they but the ceremony
that's underneath the current that's
underneath is loose sexuality and and
this is where you see pictures of the
cupid because this is cupid is greek
name is eros
yeah that's erotica uh-huh and that is
the reason why you will see in many of
the movies today erotica is an
overriding concept so the the movie
stars are in space and they're fighting
aliens and someone falls in love they're
under the ocean fighting and you know a
beast under the ocean someone falls in
love they play in baseball or basketball
somebody falls in love every movie their
fallen in love why erotica so erotica is
this concept coming out of the Greek
culture that you know push the people
towards loose open sexual relationship
and this of course is very destructive
to society not only is it going against
you know the law of God but secondly it
creates unwanted pregnancies sexually
transmitted diseases it is one of the
big problems and plagues in the world
today when people do not organize their
life take responsibility for the
sexuality there's a lot of damage that
actually comes along with it especially
for the women and so therefore we're
saying to Muslims don't play around with
the devil don't play around with evil
things and think that it is sport and
play because what is happening is that
young people are being full
into focusing their life on their
sexuality as opposed to folks focusing
their life on their education on their
physical fitness and then grow into
their sexuality this is how societies
develop themselves over the centuries
and of course the last revelation you
know of the court an brought us the
beautiful example of the husband and the
wife and the family and how people can
protect themselves and how sexuality can
actually be a beautiful thing it can be
a halal permissible thing and not
something wild and uncontrolled tell us
now for the person who is just tuning in
you know they got their friend and they
said look man this this Valentine's Day
there's more to it but you know what
it's in our public schools it's all over
the place look Johnny just wants to tell
Susie that she's cute you know what I
mean
innocent no kids are passing around
what's the big deal well of course our
again this is the wolf in sheep's
clothing wolf in sheep's clothing
meaning that it appears to be innocent
on the outside yeah and you know if a
person is if a boy is passing a comment
to a girl or vice versa there's nothing
wrong with that and in the essence the
problem is is that that the
socialization that the society itself
teaches people how to take it a step
further and so when they watch the
television programs or movies then they
will see how it goes a step further even
cartoons the two ducks you know in the
cartoons even blah blah even dr. know
duck I mean everybody's fallen in love
now yeah and so that's erotica and so
the dangerous thing is it opens up the
door you know to a bottomless pit you
know it's a dangerous area because
sexuality is a natural thing and when we
look at the Koran it tells us while that
Tucker Abu Xena in the whole kanafeh
ishutin Messiah Sibylla the court Aaron
the last Testament says do not come
close to fornication and adultery
there's well god almighty the creator
says that's what God said because it is
an abomination and it will destroy
everything in the path now other sins do
not kill do not steal do not be jealous
of your name
you know Allah says don't do it well
that tuck tool enough I let you how to
Malawi labelled hock don't kill innocent
people Allah didn't say don't commit
adultery he said don't come near
adultery
now what Islam is saying about sexuality
is very important because the creator of
the heavens and the earth is revealing
to people there are certain actions that
you shouldn't do you shouldn't kill you
shouldn't steal you shouldn't be jealous
of your neighbour you shouldn't you know
be involved in magic and taking of
interest and so forth and so on but when
it comes to adultery and fornication
Allah says well a toccata Brezina in the
who can offer a certain massage Sibylla
answer to Ezra
so it says don't come near fornication
don't come near adultery because it is
an abomination and it will destroy
everything in the past so this is a
dangerous Psalm thing it said it doesn't
say don't commit adultery and said don't
come near it now why is there a
difference between killing and adultery
because killing is not a natural thing
and any human being who sees another
person killed it should be repulsed by
that it's an ugly detestable thing but
sexuality that's what our bodies are
created for and so a man is naturally
attracted to a woman a woman is
attracted to a man so that's why Allah
said don't come near it because it's a
it's something that we want to do we are
built to do that in order for the
species you know to maintain itself
so therefore what Islam is saying is it
yes have sexuality but do it within the
confines of marriage do it in an
organized fashion where the man respects
the woman where that the other family is
set up you know where he takes care of
his children that's the way it is the
Lupercalia the valentine's erotica
concept is uncontrolled undisciplined
sexuality and it starts with that little
note sent to Jane or sent to Zainab
that's how it starts off just the
innocence but their peak hijab yeah you
know I don't know if they have pink
Goofy's on you know the pig though so we
don't know whatever it is no we don't
get involved at all and people of
consciousness Muslims those who have
kind
submitted to the one creator just the
same way as Jesus Moses because we
following that same tradition of
worshipping God alone not his creation
Muslims that was a Muslim is we should
understand this but you mentioned
earlier people for consciousness people
they're not Muslim yet we hopefully
they'll submit to the one God and do
what God wants them to do on his terms
not their desires people of
consciousness should understand this
right exactly and you'll find there are
groups in Christianity and Judaism and
other religions that know about the
history of the Lupercalia they know this
and they also are protecting themselves
and their sexuality there are Christian
groups who give out a ring they did they
pledged themselves they put on a ring
and they say we we are pledging
ourselves to be - to have sex in
marriage we're not going to be involved
in illegal sex until we get married
these are Christian groups because this
is the basis in all upstanding religions
you know to protect the family to
protect the the sexuality and therefore
you protect Society okay we're gonna
take a break and God willing we'll be
back with more here in the den shop
I'm not afraid to stand alone if you
live by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone I
am Not Afraid
oh can you put your dream home and
you've got your dream car but you're
gonna get old and things are gonna
happen to you in your life and then what
have you got at the end of the day is an
empty dream that has no real foundation
we are gonna die and we're gonna meet
our Lord and he is going to judge us it
becomes an obligation for each single
human being to find out what the Quran
is Islam is telling us to stay away from
things which are bad for your person and
bad for the society killing of innocent
human beings human life is precious
there'll always be someone that'll be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say something positive awesome just
hold on to the Rope of Allah everything
in this universe can rely a needle of
the Quran says don't kill women don't
kill children don't kill old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the Prophet Muhammad told us
if a emotional law said that the profits
are solid never ever stopped a war
existed and if we're gonna worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the Creator instead of any of
the creations now in upon investigating
the religions I remember finding out the
meaning of what Islam is what Muslim is
those who surrender their self to cut is
a Muslim those who surrender submit to
God God's will that is Islam was pure it
was just you just praise her God your
Creator back here on the Dean show with
dr. Abdul Hakim quick giving you the
roots of valentine's day showing that
it's not that innocent when it it starts
off that way but then you see what
transpires at the end you know so you
mentioned just before we get into the
next you mentioned adultery so the
person says look I'm dating I'm not like
dating anybody's wife I wouldn't do
adultery but when we say when you talk
about adultery to my any kind of
fornication yeah basically what we're
talking about is not just the physical
act of adultery but but being alone you
know with with the opposite sex
there's some one things adultery now
that's like when you even you cheat on
your husband or wife yeah I'm not
married though I got a girlfriend
yeah is that allowed Islamic Lee again
it's a complete different concept than
the loose society that people are living
in and actually if you looked at America
before 40 years even 30 years you will
see that that most people actually
waited until they were in their late
teens 20s you know before they even
started to date and before that they
wouldn't have any sexual relationships
until they were married this is how this
society actually was in the past it's
the basis of societies all over the
world and it's only recently when
erotica now enters into Hollywood and in
literature and it starts to overtake
everything and and changing society and
then you know people start you know
taking off their clothes originally when
people used to swim they had long
clothings if you look at people in early
20th century
a woman would have a bathing suit that
covered most of her body I can remember
when I was young growing up in America
in Boston and I watched a movie called
I Love Lucy yes and in that program Lucy
and her husband according to the rules
of television at that time they could
not sleep in the same bed
so therefore when nighttime came Lucy
would go to her bed and her husband will
go to his bed now look what's on
television now it's like xxx in a normal
movie is it just advancement like
advancement in technology or decline of
moral society it is actually declined
and what it is leading to is a society
that has no limits that where modesty is
gone and where respect for the family is
gone and this is very destructive and
dangerous to the whole society and we
are seeing the rise of sexually
transmitted diseases having herpes is
almost a common thing in some parts of
North America I'm shocked to see how
many people actually are carrying
sexually transmitted diseases if you
look at the amount of abortions and
onion so called unwanted pregnancies
this this is a sad case in terms of what
is happening in society and this could
be avoided by going back to the
prophetic model and that is where
sexuality is enjoyed within the confines
of marriage and the energy of the youth
is put towards building towards sports
recreation and when it comes time for
sexuality it is done within the confines
of marriage tell us now say we're almost
out of time for the person that has just
been warped their mind has just been
warped with MTV with football with you
know all the different daytime nighttime
drama so and that's all it promotes so
now but they're listening to us and
they've been contemplating what is the
purpose of life how can we direct them
to see the bigger scheme of things to
get them to really focus on why am I
here in this life who created me what
does he want for me give us that kind of
advice before we leave so we give them
something to to reflect over well my
advice for young people today is to
travel to leave the cities go into
natural settings hiking swimming in the
natural world when you go into a Las
creation then you will see the beautiful
relationship that nature has all of its
paths the animals and the trees and the
fish and the natural way of life that is
the way human beings originally created
we're supposed to be fitting into the
natural environment and we are actually
made as halifa so that we are the
representative of God we have a
protector of nature so by going into the
natural world we see a beautiful
relationships when we go into the
cyberspace and the false created world
that is where the devil's erotica takes
over and it destroys our thinking and
puts us into a dangerous way of life so
we have one minute less so is there hope
now for that person that has done you
mentioned that illegal this is something
with God that it's it's a major felony
right can you classify it like that
major law break so the person who's
broken this law with God is there still
hope for them they did everything
according to their desires but now they
want to submit to the one creator they
want to do what God wants them to do is
there hope for that person also who says
you know what you know what I got a
mountain full of sins what's what what
can I do now I've just I've taken it too
far the beauty of the last message is
that Allah Azza WA JAL tells us in
allaha ya'muru the new bohemian allah
forgives all sins so there is no sin
that is too great in this life for the
Creator to forgive we have to be sincere
no matter what it is that we did turn to
Allah make the intention and try to
change our lifestyle nobody is perfect
everybody commits sins but the best of
the sinners are those who repent that is
what the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him said so there is always hope for us
in this beautiful last way of life but
we have to be sincere and really turn to
the Creator and really try to find
alternative lifestyle that we can live
as moral beings modest beings but still
enjoy modern life and be happy and enjoy
all the beauty
society that we have today thank you
very much once again for being with us
here on the Dean show inshallah we can
be together more if God Almighty Jesus
life and there you have it Valentine's
Day explained to you you've been exposed
to the roots of it what it really means
when you're celebrating Valentine's Day
you might think it's something innocent
but look where it stems from look where
it comes from and you tell yourself and
you ask you so who should I be working
to please my desires is that all about
just satisfying my lower lusts and
desires or satisfying the one who
created me the one create or you know
what I'm gonna die and I'm gonna have to
answer for everything I did it is like
Judgment Day so now if I just been
jumping around from man and woman just
satisfying my lower lusts and desires
and not caring for the one who created
me and the laws that he sent down
through all the messages of God
including Jesus Moses Abraham the last
final messenger problem hon peace be
upon him they all came with the law of
God they all called us to worship none
but God the Supreme Being the one
creator and not the set of a partner
next to him and to obey the laws that
God Almighty has sent for us to obey and
man and woman come together inside a
marriage so don't sell yourself out
don't cop out and the guy buys you a
nice Valentine's Day chocolate candy and
tells you all them sweet nothings and
next thing you know you give yourself to
them in the wrong way and now your guilt
struck for the rest of your life you've
stained yourself you've disrespected
yourself dishonored yourself don't let
it happen and you know what even if it
did happen
you made a sin turn back to the crater
who's the most loving and ask him for
forgiveness he alone is the one who
forgives all sins and strive your best
to stay away from everything that
displeases God because our whole mission
is life is to work to please our Creator
before we meet our Creator and you have
to express yourself express your love to
God to the one creator by your actions
that's right your actions because talk
is cheap so continue to tune in here to
the Dean show every week where we have
another
sightings show waiting for you we'll see
you next time peace be with you